this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app do you
want to get paid five dollars and also
give five dollars to charity well right
now if you download the cash app and
enter the reward code Congrats
you'll receive five dollars and the cash
app will send five dollars to the times
up Legal Defense Fund isn't that great
mm-hmm the cash app is the number one
finance app in the App Store and be a
good person
download the cash app and they'll send
five dollars and be a good person
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now what up shout out to mr.
green who made that feat and it keeps it
fresh with some new congratulations
intro beats green hip hop on Twitter and
Instagram I think but the guy was out
here last week visiting and hung out
with him he has a real underground hip
hop producer he's done some mainstream
stuff mainstream stuff too but the guy
is uh one of my favorite hip hop
producers man he's so good and he
produced my favorite album ever for with
Chang Smith but yeah butters is
breakdancing when you know when dogs
itch their back it looks like they're
breakdancing every time they do that I
think it is song by Joe Budden that's
like pump of a pump pump of a pump of a
pump of a pump pump it up Burnett man
ain't no name oh dude that song you know
pump the pump pump pump of a pump of a
pump of a pump pump it up how many times
as he tried to say pump clump up a pump
pump pump up up up pump pump pump pump
pump pump it up that well it up so the
last two or two so that's 16 times
trying to say pomp hey Joe Budden you
stuttered
so yeah it's episode I don't even know
what episode it is episode 52
that's a whole year that's a whole year
worth that's a little
with his shows baby um so it's amazing
it's amazing and I thought I'd do three
episodes or four episodes and then be
done but we got a whole year and we're
going strong and I got some footage up
on my app the Chris D'Elia app if you go
and check it out on the in the store you
can log it you can get it and log in
through your phone number or through
Facebook or through your email and
you'll see some behind the scenes
footage with one fire we try to keep
them under wraps but oh my dog is
dragging his across the
carpet man dogs don't give a huh
they're naked all the time and how
up is that the dogs are naked all
the time
and they don't know and they can people
come over and they're just like well
what's up and then they run to the
person and they're naked as animals
and humans are different now man that's
one that's one reason that's one way
they're different so let's see I know
what happened actually a few weeks ago I
um no not a few weeks ago the am I
talking about wait I just got a coffee
and there was a guy playing a guitar
outside on the thing and what there's
like I would say like outside and patio
is playing a guitar I would say like 5%
of the time there's a guy playing a
guitar outside on a patio of a coffee
shop at any given time that's so
up I know we've talked about guys
playing the guitar I hate the guitar I
hate the way it sounds putting the
ding-ding-ding that's annoying to me I
hate it I hate the rock version I hate
the acoustic version even more but
that's an instrument I don't like I'm
like a grandpa that was I'm like a
grandpa that was a grandpa in the 60s
it's just like I don't like this
but I I watched this documentary called
blurred lines and now is it stupid that
they called it blurred lines because of
the viral video that came out the music
video that came out
six years ago called blurred lines with
Robin Thicke now naturally yes it's very
stupidly called the blurred lines is
about the art world now and naturally is
that very stupid no yes it's naturally
very stupid now I know some people be
like what you called your special man on
fire now naturally that was 20 years ago
that movie was and it's also making fun
of the movie naturally shut the up
before even started so naturally just
shut the up before you even start
okay but I watched the it and it's about
modern art and it's about and I and I
and I watch it because I love knowing
about art don't know much about it but I
love like like learning about what
artists are good and what artists are
bad and what people think and like
that and our basil or whatever the
you know all the pretentious that
go to Art Basel with you with their
tinted sunglasses at night and
silver hair how artist is it to be
50 and have tinted blue
sunglasses it's artists anyway they were
talking about the difference between the
difference between artists that are
recognized in history and then the flash
in the pan con artists that are just
like recognized during their generation
you know and there's this there are
these like I mean they were showing so a
lot they showed a lot of art in this
documentary and I think I I think it
comes down to this okay
look there are movies that are made and
this is art and and buildings that are
created that if you make a building
you're tech you have skill okay if you
create a building you have skill if you
make a coherent film you have skill
alright if you make a beautiful piece of
art you have skill now that's why it's
easy to tell if like in the Renaissance
like if the art was good or not because
there was some sort of realism to it you
know modern art took it all and people
started smearing feces on walls and was
like this is art now I think it comes
down to you have to have some level of
skill obviously it doesn't mean
your art needs to be pretty at all I
mean beauty is subjective of course but
if there's some level of skill to it
then okay if there's zero level of skill
to it take a train really far away okay
this thing right here the rock
on the car
there's a mercedes-benz someone
dropped the rock a huge boulder on a car
and put two eyes on the rock now is
there a level of skill involved with
that now unabashedly no you know why cuz
you drop the rock on a car now you put
eyes on it
was it was the rock heavy to lift yes
did you get a crane do it prop does it
does it does it does it is it hard to
[Music]
blow up a big oversized beach ball and
put it in a room now unabashedly no okay
do you have to have a lot to breath yeah
do we all have lots of breath do we all
have lots of time to do that if we're
gonna get paid thousands of dollars for
that beach ball now unabashedly yes
however and how about one time like cuz
there's the thing Picasso that doesn't
look real it's not realism but it takes
some level of skill to do it it looks
interesting
no does it take level
does it take does it take any sort of
skill to put a bunch of action figures
on a bust of Obama's head now
unabashedly no does it if did they make
the bust if they made the bust okay
that's hard to do that takes a level of
skill if they found the bust and put GI
Joes on it now unabashedly you
and someone will pay that
thousands of dollars religion
dude I saw on the Art Basel one well I
actually don't know if it was our Basel
or not but they had I mean my dog's
happened so I saw an Art Basel
that they they were selling these rocks
that were about the size of somebody's
chest on top of each other and each rock
was painted a different neon color and
there were four of them
hey you're gaming this is talk about
gaming the system bro I don't think
you'll find I don't know if it was our
basil but there it is
wait no no that's not it but that's what
it looked like that one on the
bottom right dude talk about gaming the
system it wasn't that big it was like a
mini version of that talk about gaming
the system dude oh man these guys are
marketers there are these guys that are
like this guy makes these what
was the guy's name who was like this
he's like this older guy and he that way
he made that one that ballooned that big
balloon on the upper left that's the guy
what's his name Jeff Koons
yeah that guy there is skill to that
there is skill to what he's doing but he
sells that he made a big blow up
Popeye that looks like this glass
fire and he using firing glass
to make it and so and and created it the
guy who owned the wind casinos said he
wanted to buy it for twenty eight
million dollars and when he heard that
he priced it at sixty million dollars
imagine buying a big Popeye for sixty
million dollars imagine buying a big
Popeye for sixty million dollars and one
of the reasons why he
made it 60 million dollars is because
when he said Popeye when he eats the
spinach and becomes strong Popeye is
like how when the art world something
about how the art he made a some
sort of analogy when the art world when
there's money involved in the art world
then the art world becomes yadda-yadda
and everyone was like uh-uh get your
white linen clothes and get the
out of here and take a train to
Busan man dude you're a idiot
man
not not Jeff Koons or Dean Koontz I keep
thinking of the artists I write
or the the author they write that's
every thriller with one word and it
shattered Dean Koontz book named
shattered Jeff Koons makes these
glass sculptures and this guy is just
murdering it dude he's worth 100 million
dollars he's worth 100 million at least
that guy has some skill but some people
put will put like a chair in a room and
be like that's eight grand hey man I got
chairs in my room you gave me the system
that's amazing do these idiot
these new money come in
because all what happened was people
inherited money and and that's how it
was for a long time like you came from
like a lineage of people with money and
now you've got these people who can make
money in like ten years
you got people who have Bitcoin
rich and they're like they're
walking in like uh this is beautiful and
they'll buy the rocks on top of each
other because definition of a CUDA man
if you buy rocks on top of each other
for thousands of dollars
you're a coda plain and simple
you are literally going because other
people are going
it's amazing dude herd mentality babies
get gunk
people are looking at these
what-do-you-call-it
exhibits I want I should come up behind
him and him in the ass Oh Oh your
nose has already faced it the same way
as my nog
convenient slip whoopsie and then people
go out and then other people come up and
like start taking beers like oh this is
if it's amazing they think it's an
exhibit because I'm a guy in the
ass and I'm just like it's like the art
world it's like the art world
and then and I just go like this Jeff
Koons made this hey this costs 11 grand
you want to send your house for 11 grand
in the 48 mm make the check out to Chris
D'Elia man this guy's looking at a
blown-up Popeye let me enter him
burp give me a thousand bucks thanks the
art world doesn't keep up with the
demand - that's the other thing so
you've got these artists that are like
oh if I don't put something out
this year for Art Basel I'm gonna be
irrelevant quick paint for rocks put
them on top of each other for real and
then these idiot Cudas will show
up and be like hmm
have you ever I guarantee the most a
group of people touches their chin is
that Art Basel in whatever that is the
moat there's never been more people
touching their gingers mm-hmm
then in when our Basil's going on oh I
see what he did here how annoying would
it be to stand next to somebody looking
at an artist art just like oh I see what
he did here how annoying would that be
oh how annoying is that the
world you know dude look up some bad art
look up bad art our Basile bad art oh my
god there's something there's a dollar
sign that somebody made there's a
look at look look look at oh
who's the girl that was an art that
makes that she's just like hung up naked
women like actual naked women you see
here's here's the thing
she hung up actual naked women and she
would there would be as expanding on
this wall with these like planks and
they'd be naked and their tits would be
out and it's a disrespectful how
I'm talking about it yeah it was naked
but the tits were out and it was hot and
yeah you liked that one piece with the
titties out I want to go to Art Basel
and do that yeah you see the exhibit
with the girls with date wood they were
on the wall and their tits were
out I liked that one that's my favorite
one
it's much better than the blown
up Popeye cuz I like to look at it
because of the tits
yeah the titties are out there big and
you can't touch it but you look a
look um should disrespectful of Art
Basel but um so and then at the left and
then in last exhibit it was like her and
she was standing on the thing and her
titties were out and that's ridiculous
to me but she's like revered it's just
she's this woman and she's revered she's
his artist and she's revered and she did
this one exhibit and every now and then
the person like that does something that
really can kind of touch you and I guess
or it speaks to different people in
different ways but here's the thing if
you're a idiot you look into it
you look into it you're an idiot if you
look into it and I know that that's the
smart thing to do a lot of people think
like oh like you know but yeah
let's see what the artist meant and the
artist and this and that like nah either
speaks here at does it cuz she
did this exhibit where she sat in a room
in a room for like days or like it was
like a bunch of out was he at least 24
hours or something I don't know there's
a bunch of hours way too long to be
sitting in a room and because she's
famous everybody was around her
videotaping her and like
watching and like they had critics and
like oh what's this new exhibiting
and she was just sitting there and her
old goal was to sit there and then
different people would sit across from
her and could experience this okay now
sounds like piece of but what
happened was a former lover of hers from
years ago came and sat down and she
started bawling and he did too
and that was crazy now call it
art call it not art whatever you want to
call it but what me up
was it was like that her old like
basically love was the only thing that
interrupted what what she was doing and
that is crazy
she was crying and he was crying and to
think of these people's history together
and I thought about that since I saw it
I'm asked a lot on video but I thought
about that since I thought about that
since I seen it almost like every other
day and that me up that like love
was the thing that that that that like
broke her from her exhibit that's it
right there
what's her name now of course her name
is something like Maria Anna Marina
Abramovic Abramovich Abram ovitch now of
course that's her name and of course she
looks the way she does because that's
what that woman would look like and
that's what her name would be her name
would never be Jan Smith you
know Marina Abramovic anyway anyway she
had a tits all out at the end of the
exhibit she had the she
was standing on a wall she had her tits
out I really like that exhibit you know
a1 we're walking in our basil one please
for the I wanna how much is it
to see the one with the tits I heard the
woman wit where's the room with the girl
with the tits in it I got singles I
don't know but then you got people like
what's his name Shia LeBouf Hayes a
shadow LaBeouf for Shia LeBouf and he
did the thing where he's like I'm not
famous and he put a and he did
the same thing
you know so it's like Shia LaBeouf a
genius an art genius oh the artist is
present is what the Marina
Abramovic thing was uh anyway that art
world is crazy
I never been our basil but it's a while
it's a wild thing
I just these guys it's all this
is to me no you know what was that what
else was funny was they were talking
about how it's like a lot of it is like
thievery and and like there should be
regulated like there's no regulation on
the art world like there's no there's no
union in place or like people
saying like people pay just way too much
for art and like that and there's
no there's no what do you call it
there's no regulations on it but but
they were saying the government doesn't
give a because it's like the top 1%
like no poor people are involved so
that's why they don't give a
they're like yeah they have billions of
dollars would be a while they're
trading each other's money which is so
true
these dead to
themselves but I like art though I want
pieces of art man you know I like art
but I mean you buy they were talking
about one painting that was three
million dollars and they were 15 years
ago and now it's 60 million dollars
imagine if you should have
bought a place in Dumbo now it's 2 mil
million but the Jews bought it Dumbo
dude I could
be an artist like that if I ever did
something like the artist is present and
I sat down I would just be sitting there
and then somebody would sit across from
me and I'd be like this guy you
know look at this piece of
and then I would start roasting them oh
come on dude or like deta have a like a
handicapped guy come like just for the
of it because you're like ooh let's
see and I'd be like ah come on you
had to be all PC and or
some baby that somebody would set their
baby on on the chair and it would start
to fall and I go to save it
and I'd be like you got you up my
exhibit you piece of or exhibit
would sit down and I'd be like oh as is
crazy it's like the inception of exhibit
this is my exhibit an exhibit of a dog
we thought we'd put an exhibit in your
exhibit it's the happiest thing to talk
about as a comedian is the pimp
your ride you know we put a fish tank in
your car but he did it how
stupid was that show exhibit exhibit was
the exhibit just give up exhibit had
like some bangers and then was like done
let's do pimp my ride done how much is
exhibit worth look up exhibits net worth
how much you think exhibit is like and I
know this is always wrong but it's
got to be what eight million dollars
what do you think
three million yeah yeah that probably
makes sense because he was on he put
that show ran but it was MTV MTV pays
you $7 and airplane peanuts MTV
gives you $40 when you're on a
show exhibit you know X Z I bi t exhibit
publicly mad about the meme that they
made about the the the pimp my
ride you know yo dog what is it yo
dog I hear you like dogs we put a dog on
a dog dog yo dawg i heard you like I
mean so many of them but why would he
was publicly mad about that dude
imagine being publicly mad about a meme
bro you did basically that show was a
meme like how are you not he's just mad
because now he's not recognized as a
rapper or an actor and you just
recognized as a meme oh yeah you made it
worse dude how come people don't realize
if you if you get bullied or
quote-unquote was not believe if you're
getting made fun of the worst thing to
do is get upset about it
how do people not know that that are
like 40 how do you not know that that
just feeds the trolls being made fun of
his hilarious and it's fun it's
part of the culture exhibit
hates exhibit meme how about that for a
2000 what do you call it
headline exquisite a culture
exhibit hates the meat that man you
make a meme about you get a meme bro you
get a meme made about you you know how
much you know how much
you know how much how many times you get
to do the horizontal mambo you know
there are girls out there that
dudes because of their Benot the guy on
the meme you know who's that guy that
that's this guy dude who's that guy
that's this guy on the meme he was like
the first meme 10 guy why is it called
10 guy salads are like plant nachos
grass is like the fur of the earth
marelize leakage wanna so dumb that
guy's face you know that guy got laid
cuz he's the meme guy imagine being that
guy look up 10 guy guys look up 10 guy
imagine being that guy you know what's
weird is that guys like 40 now you know
ice just floats around in its own blood
that's one of them imagine being that
guy dude I mean who is that guy they
need to make it and you know there's a
documentary about that guy that's on
like Amazon Prime ten guy
documentary you know that guy's guy but
that's the thing man you become a meme
that guy who blinks a lot he's blinking
this much when he's getting now
he's oh my that's how he busts is a nut
oh that that guy's famous dude like
I can never make that face again hmm and
that was years ago right drew
Scanlon no no's years ago that that
video is from a years ago I think maybe
no I don't know anyway one fires give me
all the incorrect information
yeah dude so crazy I got nominated for a
stream II was it called or no a
shorty award yeah a shorty award so go
vote on that best snapchatter
guys they got nominated for a
shorty award best snapchatter
I'm up against Chrissy Teigen and I
don't know someone else and some other
people that I don't know and then also
other people that are terrible but uh
show you boys some love who's hosting
the Shorty Awards now I don't know but
anyway uh that's cool I'm gonna read
some ads here you ready
cash app hmm the cash app is the number
one finance app in the App Store
probably because all of the babies and
the cult have been switching or is it
because it's the best way to pay people
back friends family co-workers anyone
really sending and receiving money is
totally free and fast and most payments
can be deposited directly into your bank
account in seconds the new cash card
that they have which is very cool is a
black debit card that you can design
yourself via the app and it allows you
to use the cash that you keep in the app
anywhere you want you get notifications
for all payments made with the card
directly via the cash app and you can
laser at your card to personalize it and
it will be delivered directly to you for
free if you download the cash app and
enter the reward code congrats you'll
receive five dollars in the cash app
will send five dollars to the times up
Legal Defense Fund and that's important
to us over here at congratulations you
want to get paid five dollars and also
give five dollars to charity download
the free cash app for iOS or Android now
quit if you're a person with a mouth Hey
Dude quick quest you a person with the
mouth
you got no mouth are you like are you
like Keanu Reeves when the guy takes his
mouth
way in the matrix uh-huh your person
with your mouth you most likely you
don't brush your teeth for a full two
minutes or change your brush on time or
brush twice a day if you're disgusting
clip gets that so they've designed the
perfect electric toothbrush quip is the
new electric toothbrush that packs just
the right amount of vibrations into a
slimmer design at a fraction of the cost
of bulkier traditional electric brushes
it's great I have one I use it all the
time I take it on the road and it's very
sensitive to your gums which I like
because I have Scentsy gums and because
of the thing that cleans your mouth
should also be clean crisp subscription
plan refreshes your brush on the dentist
recommended schedule delivering new
brush heads and every three months
delivering new brush heads every three
months for just five dollars including
free shipping worldwide most
toothbrushes don't get named one of Time
Magazine's best inventions of the year
but clip did hey sorry it's trying to
break you guys the news but clip did
find out why clip starts at just $25 and
right now when you get when you go to
get quick comm / congrats to get your
first refill pack free with equip
electric toothbrush
that's your first refill pack free at
get quip calm / congrats spelled GE t qu
IP comm / Congrats my favorite me undies
you want to look good with your
significant other on Valentine's Day
right dude think about that man this
Valentine's Day coming up check out me
undies matching pairs a unique fun gift
for you and your Valentine that's a
great gift that's a great gift if you're
gonna go you open it up hey this is what
gonna wear we're gonna wear on
Valentine's Day I love you sweetie it's
a perfect balance of comfortable fit
when you're out at dinner and then you
come back you take off your pants from a
romance time and you got some exciting
prints don't give the same old gift you
get chocolates and all that go to me
undies comm and that's the best mat and
find the best match for your match I
love it I think it's great it's also
cute to do that
me and these are the most comfortable
and fun undies you and your significant
other will ever own three times softer
than cotton soft Valentine's Day get
your partner a gift that's for both of
you order by February 5th at 10:00 a.m.
for free standard shipping so you're a
gift rob arrives on time 100% get
satisfaction guarantee me undies
guarantees you and your significant
other will love your matching pairs or
your money back
get your 20% off of your matching pairs
free shipping and a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee go to me undies
comm / Congrats that's me undies dot-com
/ Congrats this will be the best
Valentine's Day gift that you will give
start matching your bottom half to your
better half go to my undies calm /
Congrats right now yeah sit that's it I
got Tampa coming up I'm gonna be in
Tampa I got one a few tickets left on
the added show on The Late Thursday show
but the rest of it is sold out and I'm
working on an ounce in my neck my next
tour I'm doing the artwork and getting
it all set and I am going to be hit in
the country man and I'm excited about it
hmmm I was at the Pasadena ice house
this past weekend man the ice house is
awesome I did four shows there and it
was great you got to get out to that
club man that room is so cool holds
about 200 people it's very intimate and
and it was great man my love I love
doing stand-up man I love figuring out
the whole new hour it's just so fun when
I started doing stand-up when I started
doing stand-up I was like I was
literally like a switch went off I was
like dude this is what I this is oh okay
it makes sense Who I am now in the
business and I think about that all the
time
the dude
I the government shutdown which is
amazing because it's not blockbuster the
government shutdown which is amazing
because it's not we're we're a
house music remember that place
where house music with a bi compact this
there and Trump was like in 2011 was
like hey if the government shuts down
it's the president's fault and now the
president his fault according to his own
words I saw a guy on my youtube channel
that commented I used to listen to Chris
D'Elia on I used to listen to every
episode but now I don't because every
episode he bashes Trump blocked him
I got a trigger finger block finger baby
I'll block you understand dude am I a
lineman am i a lineman am i an
off dude I've been losing sleep over
this last thought am i a nose tackle
because what happens when some when I go
online and look at comments I block so I
think I maybe I'm a nose tackle dude I
will block you if I'm in a mood that's
the best part you never know what
crystal he's gonna get hey man
great job I roll emoji trigger finger
block finger am i dude all of a sudden I
became a nose tackle all of a sudden
there's a cloth tucked into my waist
hanging over my all of a sudden I
got shoulder pads on cuz I'm about to
block you and guess what the best part
about getting blocked you never get
unblocked and I mean this unless you get
cancer and write me and say I'm dying
and I have cancer and I need then you
need to unblock me because it's my dying
wish or you stay and blocked
have you know how many people write me
oh my friend got blocked he doesn't know
why oh really
if he doesn't know why even more blocked
fav you know why more block fav because
you just willy-nilly talked and
don't remember dude you made your bed
lay in it your bed has a nose
tackle in it you're blocked following me
anyone is a privilege it's not a right
it's a privilege that's why it's a
privilege if you're a part of my cult
it's a privilege to know the address of
the log cabin do you want to know where
the trail is that leads there act
accordingly do you want to sit
indian-style with me outside in patchy
grass wearing the same thing as me then
don't talk and enough with the I
roll emojis I put this tweet that kind
of got a lot of tweets retweets sounds
so old guy I put this tweet that got a
lot of retweets and it said this it said
this uh here we go here we go here it is
okay I wrote it really worries me how
offended everyone is about everything
nowadays everyone wants to be on the
side of whatever makes them look like a
good person online there's new ones it's
not black and white people can be right
and wrong at the exact same time and
then in the follow-up tweet I wrote get
off your keyboard and go start a
charity if you mean it if not then stop
typing and go shopping swimming
exercising whatever the makes you
stop whining like a child with no cookie
I swear to god you're going to ruin
comedy and then society
and some idiot chick wrote back
to me oh look the guy who's the guy who
start on whitney is worried about
ruining comedy and i retweeted her
follow me on stage and we will see when
comedy gets ruined now after that she
shut the up
because she knew it was best for because
she the congratulations baby dude
everyone for a fact after today slammed
and like everyone's throwing
gifs and this girl got hit by a
wave this guy put a slam dunk thing she
like people like and and then I looked
at her and it's terrible you know
she's one of those terrible
feminists that think that everything is
wrong what a guy does you know which is
hilarious
I feel like feminists are eating
themselves man like a hundred percent
women are should have equal all the
Equality period no matter if you're
black and white Asian woman man
who gives a you should all have
equality you know but dude I saw a
tennis of charity tennis match
online and the guy that it was a guy in
a girl versus a guy in a girl and the
guy and the girl were hitting the ball
to each other and not hitting it to the
women and somebody was like this is
toxic masculinity hey man dude you're
eating yourself you're eating yourself
you're ruining it you're ruining your
movement you're eating yourself you made
people vote for Trump who hates women
[Laughter]
you're the problem you're the problem
man
you can't eat that
just goes back to the Art Basel thing
our Basel thing if you're looking for a
meaning you are a CUDA it has to
jump out at you man
if you're looking for a piece to
fit inside another piece you're missing
the point it's like these people
who look for a significant other you're
not supposed to do that
you're supposed to let it find you
otherwise it's not real love dude
men and women are different that's okay
men are stronger physically that's it
yeah generally you know there's
definitely women out there that can lift
more weights than me but men are
physically stronger than women if you
want to argue that sayonara you're a
idiot
period women are better at communication
if you disagree with that
well I mean there are men that are out
there that are really great
speakers and but like women are
better than at listening and
understanding because they give a
about people more I know that because I
don't do that
I'm a dude that's like yeah I
get it I get it
I'm an idiot
yeah you sure sure yeah I get it oh man
I don't know I don't know I'm just
talking out of my ass but my point is
stop looking for the pieces okay
stop looking for the pieces if you're
just somebody with a keyboard
how about that look for the pieces if
you gotta if you're a doctor or
if you went to school for 47 years but
just because you hold the sign
and you got a short haircut
doesn't mean you found all the
pieces man hmm I don't know movements
are great you know but they feel like
they just eat themselves all the time
like like the woman's March is
great it's great they need to be
out there and we need to be out there
and support that I just feel like
so many of them don't even know why
they're there and I guess it doesn't
matter if the end result is they get
what they want or they get what's
absolutely needed but it's just so funny
man
like like the me to so many people
are calling out this girl whose name is
quote/unquote grace that called out Aziz
Ansari and they're saying like hey you
went on a bad date so many people
feminists are saying yo you're
ruining the me to movement because this
was a bad date and you consensually blew
him and then could have left a bajillion
times and didn't and now you're like he
assaulted me uh I think
basically if you have if you willingly
blew someone and there wasn't a gun
involved yeah you know
and nobody's blocking a door get out and
and and and feminists and women and men
and their royal Issus like dude come on
help out a little bit look if I keep
going down the same alley and keep
getting mugged you know yeah people are
like oh well don't victim blame but also
you avoid that alley and you know
it's I'm not saying the mugger what the
mugger did is right but come on you know
help out a little bit I'm not saying
what Aziz his behavior was
gentlemanly but I don't know
now she like single-handedly
ruined this movement I mean no I
don't think she ruined the movement I
think the movement cuz that movement is
important man
we need these we need i
dude I want to beat the out of guys
like Harvey Weinstein I hate that I
hate it dude it there needs to
be some sort of leveled playing field
here when it comes to the workplace but
dude you went out on a date with in Aziz
Ansari and he wanted some it's the
age-old he wanted some and you
didn't want to give it to him also
why did you go out with him cuz he's a
movie star cuz he's a TV star he wasn't
doing what you wanted dating you
treating like a treating you
like a real person dude there's a door
there's a doorman walk through it I mean
dude he's okay I'll stop let's sit on
the couch and watch a movie yeah see
yeah okay maybe now he'll want to date
me oh he's touching my titties
again I mean this is what everyone's
saying upset about and like
that
everyone I talked to rolls our
eyes at that story I mean I don't know I
know I'm around people that I'm
around and not around super uh left
people but uh yeah it's just that that
article and also here's the other thing
man if you're gonna call out a guy for
that
don't be anonymous you're trying to ruin
this guy's career but like hey
nobody knows
- I am NOT you need to be subjected to
what the you subjected him
to I'm sure people are hating what the
I'm saying but I'm not excusing his
behavior I don't know I don't even
really know I don't know the guy that
well I don't know what the how he
treats women shed I don't know I don't
know I never know I'm always the last
guy to find out about like that man
when people talk people tell me what
Louie was doing I was like what
everyone's like oh you didn't know that
I'm like no I no idea I never
know that I don't know why I never
know that people could be like did
you know Jerry Seinfeld is a
killer and he's any and he has heads in
his freezer and I'd be like what a dick
oh yeah there was an article about it in
the 90s but they kind of covered it up
then I asked everyone around it be
clicks it's like census freezers all
around the country he actually has a
bunch of places he keeps watch it
he has storage units just full ahead
I don't know you know Kanye went to Art
Basel there's no way in hell Kanye
didn't go to art basel there's no way in
hell if i could bet all my money on one
thing is that kanye west went to art
basel pictures or basel Kanye and
obviously hit images there is Kanye's
Art Basel Darius hey what do you know
hey how about how he named his son her
son this is a girl Chicago I say Chicago
West dude everything that guy does is to
get attention in the media it's just
like this is like unbelievable
everything he does is to get attention
good or bad look at these articles on us
go up scroll up khloe kardashian reveals
how chicago West's nickname is
pronounced I couldn't think of something
that I don't care about less than that
who gives a how you pronounce Kanye
West's daughter's nickname did imagine
caring about that and clicking on that
imagine caring about that oh dude I
gotta know how cuz I'm gonna be talking
about and I'm beep embarrass myself shy
oh it's shy how about how his daughters
are named Chicago and North what the
dude
remember when Gweneth Paltrow named a
kid Apple that kids got to be 35
now or some Apple Paltrow but it
was with him was probably Apple Martin
no because she's been doing it with
Chris Martin Apple Martin sue how old is
she now
13 Wow yeah 13 years ago but when people
are like wow they got old as I get time
happens
oh so better names Apple huh
it's stupid these are the names
you pick Casey Kent Ralph J Jane Robert
Matt David Dan Rebecca Lisa you know
what you don't name a kid Audio
science well who was that one Shannyn
Sossamon girl girl and boy Audio science
pilot inspector hey that kids
there's no way Audio science and pilot
inspector isn't going to go to Art Basel
when they grow up dude
pilot inspector just the visual of what
that is is like I imagine like somebody
like looking at a pilot like
lifting up their balls and like looking
under their armpits and like okay
he's good pilot inspector how up
do you have to be to name your kid pilot
inspector and if you're if you name your
kid pilot inspector you better wear a
cape every day go for it go for
it you can't be Nate you
can't be naming your kids like that
and and not go full throttle and just
like you can't be naming your kid pile
inspector and be like I gotta go to a
Best Buy today and see what cuz
I gotta get a cat in a SIM card
let's look at these names Moon
Unit Zappa put Ptolemy what these are
the names
know how the poppy honey Rosie Daisy boo
petal blossom these are all these
famous idiots
Fifi Trixie Bell is that the name denim
coal band Italy their way oh those are
dogs well then what the it matter
here we go come on
what was it good you got to go in too
fast kid that's one Nakoa wolf manic
kaupo Nemec a hama MOA oh that's yeah
but that's like some that's like their
culture or some you know yeah and
like they got like they he's so Hawaiian
dude have you seen even if he's not
Hawaiian he's wine have you seen
that video on Jason Momoa where he like
produced it and it's all about his life
and and he's just like throwing
axes at trees and and he
and ended playing with his kids and he
was just like talking it's it's so
pretentious I I like Jason Momoa I'm not
I'm not even talking but that video
is just like all slow-motion and he's
tickling his kids and he's got paint on
his pants like a real guy kids are my
life I never knew what I had until I had
kids you know that kind of a vibe I'm
all about work I like to get my hands
dirty it's like that kind of a thing and
you keep waiting for it to be like oh
what's this a commercial for and then it
just ends and you're like oh he just
made this and it went viral
and and and housewives are just like if
I could only if I could only
girag okay all right here we go this is
the worst one I think maybe I mean I
don't know if it's worse than
pilot inspector that may be the worst
one ever
but Jermaine Jackson has a lot of kids
okay uh these are all those names okay
Jeremy okay sure Jeremy there you go
Jordan fine but now we're getting a
little iffy cuz it's spelled j o u rdy
nn-no naturally you should unabashedly
spell it jo r da and otherwise you
complete piece of but he did it now
granted he did it because he was
molested as a kid that's the thing if
you get molested as a kid you got a more
chance of definitely naming your
kid some up weird and
spelling it in a weird way now granted
lost subscribers by saying that but got
to keep it real for babies you got to
keep it real for the babies if you get
molested if you get molested you have a
chance if you get molested you have a
higher chance of naming your kid
something weird like Moon Unit
or spelling Jordan Jo u rdy NN Jafar
Jackson there's one now begin Aladdin no
your cartoon no name um Tom Mecca and
Medinah
alright Mecca no Medina maybe here's the
one though that makes me want to throw
myself down a flight of stairs
your majesty
I mean come on dude jerm a gist e dude
imagine
at Applebee's and being like yeah four
please okay what should I put it under
your majesty if I worked at Applebee's
here's where I would say no give me
another name I'll put it under fill' and
you just respond to Phil here's your
ticker when it buzzes come over
here Phil jerm a gist II do names
names that are where you're like how do
you spell it
nah
Roger cool
ROG er no no it's spelled r aw Jay o R
no no you know what I'll spell it ROG er
cuz that's raw jour hello I am Raj our
Moon Unit Oh Nick Nolte's kid Brawley
King I don't even know these names are
so up wait hold on stop it there
across his three marriages John Cougar
Mellencamp has collected a wide array of
kids with head-turning names this is
real his name is kid's name is HUD HUD
Teddy Joe justice but the one that takes
the bitch-ass cake
wild horse that's his kids name spec
wild horse Wow if I ever meet John
Cougar Mellencamp I'm gonna literally be
like yeah hey what's up I'm Chris hey
what what's the deal what were you
thinking man what's what what's what
were you thinking
and he knows deep down what I'm talking
about
that's how up that name is he
would say what do you mean and I'm
saying you know you know what I mean man
what what's the deal with the whole
thing with why you did that and he'd be
like finally we would get to the point
where he'd be like you talking about why
I named my kid spec wild horse and I'm
like of course why did you do it
and then he would put his head
in his palms eventually and probably
start crying and be like because I
really needed them to go to Art Basel
and that's how the only way I knew that
they would go I needed them to buy rocks
on top of each other I needed them to
buy boulders on cars I'm gonna read some
tweets here we go
you got some one fire he does one hunter
one hire did
yeah that's here's the thing going to go
back to that one John at JMA one
underscore thoughts on man caves now
here's the deal it's for sure cool and
fine to have a bunch of your stuff if
you're married no you know what dude
here's the deal if your whole house is
for the woman in the relationship but
you get one room to do what you want
with you're a you're a
ass all right it's
okay
have a room that's a little more for the
guy but the real thing I have a problem
with is if you call it a mancave
it's a room with your stuff in it that's
that if you say this is my man cave even
as a joke you can't be in my cult I
haven't heard this song this guy's
talking about Drake's new song God's
love I mean sounds like a Drake song
more life is saqqaq you know the name
what do you think of birthday cards with
pop outs and the ones that play music
John Lindros gentleman draws one yeah no
I mean I don't know they're fine you
know I feel like sometimes you guys are
looking to stuff too much that's not
that big of a deal I mean cards are
stupid anyway you gotta write in it and
to say happy birthday to somebody
wrapping gifts just put in a bag
how about that ass way of putting
it in a bag and putting tissue over it
like you don't really give a about
somebody you know you're like ah here
you go here's a bag with some tissue on
it I don't really give a about you
I just cut that I had a bit about that I
cut it out of my last special I think I
don't think it's in there where it's
about people who don't wrap presents
they just put it in the bag with
sparkles on it and put pink tissue paper
over it you hate that person
straight up you you deep down resent
that person because you're like oh I
didn't wrap it for you at crystally are
you working any material from the
podcast into your stand-up this is from
William Rodriguez at we cried WC
Rodriguez 55 yeah I guess I am it but
that just so happens I'm not I'm not
trying to do it when I do that it just
ends up happening like I talk I think I
touched on some Australia stuff in my
podcast and I talked about it in the pot
and I'm on stage now
because I was they realized that I could
turn it into a bit but that's how I get
material is just from talking you know
with friends and like that
anyway let me look and see if I had a
most up Instagram post of the
week you guys send me great from
that I love it how I have it saved in my
instagrams as oh oh oh good gunk now
granted the internet isn't fixed now the
internet isn't she pulling it up now
what the deal is now here's a home I'm
mad I'm mad at one fire because it's his
a thing to make sure my internet goes
really fast
mmm here's a good one here here here's a
good one do I like this one okay guys
you ready from the most it's time for
them it's time for the most up
Instagram post of the week hey guys I
don't even know if I did this one but I
may have done this one but I'm doing it
again dude this is so up I don't
think I did this one it's his guy and
he's a fitness guy and he's standing
outside somewhere with a shirt on in
shorts on he's buff and of course he
looks like Johnny from the Karate Kid
this is what the caption is tell me the
story bro wait alright this is actually
so good for most of up most
up Instagram post of the week but
it's also so good for Sephora Instagram
post of the week alright when guys look
so American but then are foreign it's
even funnier dude because it's like
they're trying to hide it and it's not
even their fault it's their face this
guy looks like he's from Sweden and also
could be just a surfer dude
tell me the story bro this story
dot-dot-dot
what story question mark dot okay okay
bruh hashtag Asia what the man
ah I tell you something yesterday
evening when I arrived in Zurich first
of all Asia and Zurich for one moment I
asked myself period if I just awaked
from a dream period was that real I mean
dot dot the last week's
was that real question mark question
mark question mark Fork
I cannot believe what this trip showed
me and bro man it was no
dream all that really happened I cannot
believe what I just did I never was in
holidays or travel to anywhere and now I
was flying across the plane
it's so crazy to believe that an
airplane takes me 1,100 kilometers and
so foreign without stops and then you
get off the plane walking period walk
into another world period I'm from a
small town man
period well that's odd I wouldn't guess
that I'm a real simple man all the crazy
things that happened on that trip
goddamn brah cannot tell you everything
too freaky
tio but I can tell you I'm like if you
really want to know how it feels like
you got to try it
exclamation point so I tried everything
that crossed my way no risk no fun huh
happens but funny shot as well bro
hahaha okay okay should be it for today
thanks to everyone who were involved
smiley face chakra emoji
but this is not the end I got my
supplements and now my camera bro so I'm
ready to go again I'm coming for more
and then a bunch of hashtags what yeah
if this guy didn't kill himself after
this now safar n' so lifes unraveling
the most up Instagram post of the
week
dude this is his life's unraveling it's
unbelievable dude how'd you find it so
quick
yeah dude I mean so funny and I wish you
saw the post because he's got he
looks like Johnny from The Karate Kid
okay wow dude
just wow I gotta go all right that was a
great one I mean when I first saw
that when I was having good guys got so
many followers
alright I gotta go but you guys thank
you so much for listening and here's the
deal download my app and also check out
my website Square couch wait check out
my website for the dates coming up I'm
announcing the tour soon
square square cash have you switched yet
download the free square cash app enter
rewards Co congrats get $5 give $5 -
times up get it for iOS or Android now
your tour coming up subscribe to the
YouTube channel watch the videos for the
podcast subscriber rate and review do it
and tell people about this podcast
because um I don't give a if this
isn't growing I'll stop it straight up
not even threatening just will Tampa win
a pick Tampa win a pick out Calgary
Saskatchewan Cleveland working on dates
coming up for Denver Chicago all the
good ones Seattle man I'm firing
corrigible watch Mike white male black
comic on common sense calm
I'm on the show the pilot of it alone
together
and I'm one or two other episodes but
thanks for listening you guys are the
best and I have an announcement coming
soon to project one but you guys are
great thanks to my babies
remember unabashedly
[Music]